continúa la tensión entre armenia y
azerbaiyán este miércoles el ministerio
de defensa armenio acusó a su
contraparte de romper la tregua
negociada la jornada anterior esta noche
las fuerzas armadas de azerbayán
dispararon contra infraestructura
militar y civil utilizando drones de
ataque y por la mañana comenzaron un
intenso bombardeo de artillería en
particular las posiciones de combate y
los asentamientos fronterizos ubicados
en la dirección de helmut y béring soria
al tiempo que los enfrentamientos se
intensifican los familiares de los
heridos se acercan a los centros médicos
para conocer alguna noticia de sus seres
queridos nos enteramos de que mi hermano
estaba herido primero estuvo en la
provincia de sunny y luego fue
trasladado aquí
muchos expresan su enfado por lo que
describen como otra provocación por
parte de azerbaiyán
aunque nuestra voluntad es
indestructible pero debemos ganar como
sea debemos luchar por nuestra tierra
por nuestra patria y por nuestro país
por supuesto era de esperar una nueva
guerra dada la acumulación de
azerbaiyanos en la frontera
los ataques de este martes por parte del
ejército acería las posiciones armenias
destacadas cerca de la frontera fueron
los enfrentamientos más violentos desde
el alto al fuego del 10 de noviembre de
2020 según bakú los soldados a series
sólo respondieron a una provocación